So who's my guest this week?
It's the former senior White
House advisor, Fiona Hill.
It was one of the most
compelling appearances
during the Trump impeachment hearings.
Blunt, composed and incredibly distinctive
with her strong Northern English accent.
President Trump's top Russia expert
was devastating in her
assessment of policy and culture
in Trump's White House.
Her warning about Putin's
danger to the West
and how American ideals that
were so appealing to her
were under threat.
Putin is always looking out to see
if there is any hint that
we will not follow through
on promises that we have made,
because he will always
follow through on a threat.
Fiona Hill's journey from
a poor English mining town
to working for three
presidents in Washington
is documented in her book,
There Is Nothing For You Here.
Where she takes her story of
social mobility and opportunity
and argues that class and racial barriers
are still holding too many back.
Here's a bit of what's coming up.
And imagine if Trump
had actually succeeded on January 6th
and the members of the
January 6th committee
in the US Congress are pretty convinced
that we were very close to him succeeding,
had not Vice President Pence
basically refused to block the
transfer of executive power.
I mean, we'd be in a
totally different place.
I mean, Vladimir Putin
would've probably just
driven right into Ukraine himself.
Fiona, thank you so much
for coming to talk to us.
Thanks, Emma glad to be with you.
Really interested to hear
what you have to say,
especially because for a lot of people,
they wouldn't have heard of you
before that first impeachment inquiry
in which you appeared,
and I wonder for you, do
you replay that moment?
Do you think about it?
And what do you think about?
I actually don't.
I mean, maybe that sounds
a little bit strange,
but it was kind of...
It's one of those things
where you're so focused in the moment,
that when you come out again,
it's almost like it didn't happen
because it was such an intense
period of concentration,
a lot of effort leading up to it.
And then, you know, the kind of aftermath
was sort of moving onto the next thing,
because so much happened
as a consequence of that
that I hadn't anticipated
that I find it very kind
of hard looking back to it.
I find it fascinating in your book,
you talk out this being
prepared for the room,
that it was gonna be quite cold,
and also how you looked as a woman.
All these things had to be factored in
when I'm sure you just wanted
to give the information.
Exactly.
I mean, I didn't know I'd
have to think about this.
I mean, literally one of
the very first questions was
we're gonna have to figure
out what you're going to wear.
I thought, what?
And I said, well, does that happen to men?
They said not so much.
But the point is that
as a woman, you know,
people are already wondering who you are
and they literally said to me,
you don't want to be a
distraction from the truth.
And the reason I wanted
to put this in the book
is that most times when men write a book,
nobody asks them about
how it is to be a man.
Nobody even kind of thinks about
what it is that they were wearing
or the particular setting.
And they just go there
and they do their job.
I mean, yes, if you're
gonna appear on television,
everybody now these days
with high definition TV
has to have some makeup
on and their head done,
because otherwise they
look like they've died,
kind of become just the
whole bright lights effect.
But for something as serious
and consequential as a testimony,
I thought the whole fact that
there was focus on how I would look
as part of my presenting myself
so that people would listen to my answers
and just for telling the truth,
I mean, that really hit me
and thought about, you know,
what a difference it
really is to be a woman
in these kinds of settings.
And what did you do?
How did you make sure you were listened to
in terms of how you looked
and then how did you feel?
Did you have to wear extra layers?
Did you have to take the advice?
I did and I had a really good PR person,
a woman that I've mentioned in the book
called Molly Levinson,
who did this for a living and had been in
the broadcast media as well as a producer,
but who had worked with people
in these kinds of settings
for a long period of time.
And she literally went
through my wardrobe.
She said, you know, you have
to look a particular look.
She said that we'll be picked up
by the Washington Post style section.
Well, that look was,
when we were picked up by the
Washington Post style section,
which I was pretty incredulous
about at the beginning,
they said we were reassuringly dull.
So that was what she was looking for,
because I was basically
testifying with another person,
David Holmes, from the US embassy in Kiev.
Did he look reassuringly dull?
Well, I thought he looked
quite smart, actually.
But the whole view was, you know,
reassuringly dull bureaucrat look.
There was a Fiona Hill fan club
that sort of sprung up online
actually from across the
spectrum in some ways
as people heard what you
had to say and stayed,
a lot of people talking about
how focused you stayed on the facts.
And some of those almost
we'll get to through your expertise,
but did you feel it was
a good use of your time
or do you feel it was
a waste of your time?
Because ultimately it didn't work.
I had John Bolton on,
the former National Security
Advisor to Trump very recently
and he didn't testify
because he thought it
would be a waste of time.
It depends on what your
perspective is about
waste of time or good use of time.
In the United States,
there is still this
concept of civics education
where people fully understand
how their government works
and especially important
in something like a
representative democracy,
liberal democracy where
you as the regular person
wants to feel that your public servants,
your members of Congress,
your members of Parliament
are actually taking your
interest into consideration
and listening to you.
And understanding that there
are checks and balances
on executive power,
particularly on abuses of power,
which this was clearly the case
and this whole definition
of crimes and misdemeanors
and how does this process play out?
It was an exercise in liberal democracy.
It's the checks and the balance,
the oversight of Congress.
But ultimately it didn't work.
Yeah, but it showed people
that the system was there,
and that everybody got to hear the truth.
And I think a lot of
people came away from that
realizing that it was wrong
for basically Donald Trump
to ask Volodymyr Zelenskyy,
the president of Ukraine
for a personal favor.
Now, the political outcome of this,
the partisan political outcome of this
was of course that there was
no censure even of Trump.
He didn't get any kind of penalty,
just it wasn't even a wrap
on the knuckles or the wrist
from any perspective.
And as Ambassador
Bolton, John Bolton said,
well, look, it seems
to be a waste of time,
if anybody was really expecting
there to be some massive
outcome for Trump himself,
I think he'd actually also emboldened him
to go onto the next thing that
he got impeached twice for.
Were there any negative outcomes
for you being out there and
effectively going viral?
Oh, there was a lot.
I mean, there was all kinds of misogyny
and sexism and threats
and threats of bodily harm
and kind of all kinds of--
How did they come to you?
Mostly through the internet.
So I just stopped engaging.
I mean, my sister who
was constantly monitoring
Twitter and Facebook and
things would give me warnings
and she would get in
touch with the platforms
to try to get people to take down
some of the most outrageous things.
I'd get phone calls, letters, emails.
But actually, I have to say
that it was a smaller percentage
than what was really an overwhelming,
I would say a positive response
in terms of just thank
you for telling the truth.
And again, everybody can tell the truth.
So, I didn't think it
was that extraordinary.
And again, there was a lot of
other people who did testify,
my colleagues, I mean the
people have got to know as well.
I really took away from that
that there was a kind of a great thirst
for people just standing up there
and telling things like they are.
Talking about what you know,
and your expertise, of course, it's Russia
and it's hugely in demand right now,
and I wanted to talk about Ukraine
from the perspective of
all you have looked at
and all you're looking at right now.
Do you think the conflict,
the war was inevitable?
I don't actually.
I mean, I think there's all kinds
of junctures along the way in everything,
where things can take a different path.
I think that what happened
in terms of the decision
making of Vladimir Putin
is he thought, you know,
there was a number of things going on.
First of all, he thought
the west had lost the plot,
that we'd become very weak and distracted,
that indeed all we're doing
is engaging with partisan
fights with each other,
identity politics, you name it,
but he saw over a long period of time,
an inability for the west to
stand up to it's own values
and it's own principles,
particularly when it came to
pressure on other countries.
So Ukraine was in the cross hairs.
Going back to in fact the early 2000s
and even back into the 1990s
and we didn't really do anything.
So when Georgia was invaded back in 2008,
each time we'd find an excuse
to not really take very strong measures.
I also think that two years
of COVID had an impact.
Like the rest of us, he
was kind of sitting down,
you know, hunkered down,
excluding people from coming close to him,
not wanting to get sick,
but he also became more and more isolated.
We could see from the people
who used to get access to him.
So he starts to be basically shrunk down
in his terms of advice
to a smaller and smaller group of people,
and clearly he convinced himself
that he could get away with this
and that there would be no backlash
either in Ukraine or
anywhere else in the west.
But do you think, I mean, for instance,
you've mentioned a whole series of events
leading up to this,
but for instance, there
are some now saying
that the presidency of Trump
and the attack on January
the sixth on the capital
was a moment, a particular moment.
Did you buy into that?
From Putin's point of view?
Exactly.
I mean, look, the United States
looked like it was finished.
And imagine if Trump had actually
succeeded on January sixth
and the members of the
January sixth committee
in the US Congress are pretty convinced
that we were very close to him succeeding
had not Vice President Pence
basically refused to block the
transfer of executive power
and had agreed in fact to just go ahead.
Pushed ahead rather than agreed to it.
I mean, disagreed with what
Trump was asking him to do
and had basically certified
the electoral votes.
I mean, we'd be in a
totally different place.
I mean Vladimir Putin
would've probably just
driven right into Ukraine himself,
because he then would've
seen the United States
as completely finished from
a leadership perspective,
because we would be no different
from any other country in the world
that had just had a coup.
How concerned are you about
nuclear conflict at this moment in time?
Well, I'm very concerned
about some one sided action
on the part of Putin,
and I think it's very
important for all of us
to put that into a context
and not be intimidated by it
because that's exactly
what he wants to do.
Putin wants to take us
all back to the 1980s
and the euro missile
crisis and war scares,
or back to the days of
the Cuban Missile Crisis,
where everyone's thinking
they've got to duck and cover again.
Putin is a kind of a free agent maverick
when it comes to this.
He's sort of in a way
revived the Soviet era
instruments of nuclear missiles
and biological and chemical weapons,
he's already used chemical weapons
with novichok and polonium,
I mean, here in the United Kingdom,
in assassination attempts, for example.
During the Syrian war, after
the Russians intervened,
there was lots of
chemical weapons attacks,
lots of threats of all
kinds of things going
and just by rhetorically putting out there
the prospect that he might
use a nuclear weapon,
talking about the
chances that he might use
a tactical battlefield nuclear weapon,
he's trying to get us all scared
so that we back off
and then basically agree
to surrender Ukraine
or whatever else it is
that he's demanding.
But do you not believe it then?
I suppose that's what--
I believe that he's
thinking about doing it,
but I think that what we need to do
is to push back against that
because we need to
understand why he's doing it.
He's doing it because he feels
on the back foot right now.
He hasn't been able to
press forward with the aims
in the way that he wanted them
politically and then militarily.
And he's doing it because he figures
we're gonna get scared.
So how do you do this with him?
I mean, you talk as if,
right, we need to understand him.
You're giving some of the
expertise that you've got,
the intelligence as well that
you will have heard about,
but how do you negotiate with Putin?
Well, what you have to do is
get a full court press on him here,
because Putin wants this all to be about
just his discussions with Biden
or just his discussions
with kind of the west.
Because again, Ukraine is
one of the objects here
and the other object is rolling back NATO
and getting rid of the United
States in European affairs.
But what he's doing
has global consequences
and we need China, we need India,
we need other countries to push back.
Japan and South Korea get it.
And I mean, they've been
very much supportive,
but we need to get more than that.
We need to be able to
show the rest of the world
that this has global consequences
and this isn't just an east west spat,
but it's just not possible
to keep moving forward.
Denying components to the
Russian military for the war,
not just giving more weapons to Ukraine,
problems of accessing the funding,
basically making...
Heading him off at every pass,
but diplomatically, if
he's hearing it from
not just the NATO countries,
not just the west, not just
the sort of usual suspects,
but quietly from others saying,
look, what you're doing here
is having terrible
consequences for us as well,
famine in Africa,
kind of really putting on edge
security elsewhere in the world,
that's when we might have
a chance of pushing this
in a different direction.
I mean, I suppose what
you're talking about there is leadership
and who's going to be doing that,
and if they're doing that
and you have worked for three presidents,
but only known by one as Russia bitch?
Were you actually known as that?
Apparently.
I mean, I didn't know that in real time,
I learned that later from
an American journalist
who was doing some interviews
for a piece afterwards.
And this was how you--
I was not surprised .
Were referred to by Donald Trump?
Well, by some of the people around him.
He himself never said that.
I don't think so.
I think that gives a window
though into the climate
within which you were working,
especially as an expert
on Russia and as a woman.
Yeah, very much so.
It's just that kind of casual misogyny,
who does she think she is,
that woman who works on Russia?
It's kind of obvious.
I mean, I wasn't the
slightest bit surprised
when I heard that.
I mean, I was a bit surprised
that I felt the particular
person it was attributed to
had even noticed who I was.
So I thought, oh, well, I
guess they did know who I was.
I wonder because of
what you're saying here,
were you actually listened
to by Donald Trump?
I don't think he listened to anybody,
but apart from people who we saw as peers.
I mean, that's why we saw in
weirdness in real time of him
with Putin, talking about Putin
being strong and powerful,
and he was listening to Putin
over his intelligence chiefs for example,
at the summit in Helsinki and
that dreadful press conferences.
We knew that he listened
to people on Fox News
and on other media outlets.
Many of the people, including
ambassador Bolton and others
would try to get on the Sunday shows
because they knew that
he would be watching.
They were more likely to
have him listen to them
if they were on the TV screen,
than he would listen if
he was in the oval office.
And there's all that kind
of bizarre creativity
that had to go on to get his attention
because if you went in and you sat down,
you were just his staff.
So he basically projected.
But that sounds like it's men and women,
or would you say it was worse for women?
I think it was worse for
women, but not all women.
I mean, there were some women
that he respected and listened to
like Kellyanne Conway and
his daughter, Ivanka Trump.
But once a person started working for him,
no matter what they had been before,
that status disappeared.
I mean, he projected onto the government
the same style I presume that
he had in his private business
when it was the Trump family enterprises
and everyone was then the staff.
So why would he listen to them?
I mean, in that context,
information and
recommendations and direction
trickled down from him,
not up if you're in an
eponymous family firm,
it's your brand, your firm,
you just tell other people,
you know, what to do.
In the case of the U.S.
government they're supposed
to be much more, you know,
advisors are supposed to be advisors,
national security advisor
knows their stuff,
they're supposed to be
able to have a say in this,
they're coordinating all the
way across the government.
And as far as Trump was concerned,
we were all some version of staff.
If you were called Secretary of State
or Secretary of Defense,
you were just a glorified secretary.
If you were a woman,
you were pretty likely to
be a regular secretary.
Did you take this in your stride?
Did it get to you?
I know you'd been on the women's march
and then you accepted this job
because you wanted to contribute
and put something back and help.
Yeah, I mean, I wasn't
deluded in that sense.
I mean, what I think really did get to me
was just the dirty politics.
Because again, I'm not a partisan person,
I'm politically engaged,
politically active, but I'm not political.
I've never been on a political campaign.
And just this Game of Thrones,
kind of people stabbing
each other in the back,
I mean, yeah, it happens
in every political system,
but there's just the dirty corruption
behind the scenes as well.
I did really genuinely think
that people would understand
on the national security front
that you needed to check all of that.
When it came to certain issues,
really critical issues where
American lives were at stake
or the whole stability of the
globe, let's put it that way,
people would check themselves.
I was shocked to find they
didn't and that's what got to me.
Well, you also said that
being groped in the
seventies and eighties,
working in a golf club,
had been preparation, good
preparation for working--
Yeah, I would've preferred
not to have that,
and actually, let's just be very clear,
nobody did that to me in the White House,
but you know, just--
No, but the point being, as a context
is an extraordinary piece of
help almost that you cited
when working in this particular--
Yeah, I mean, that was
kind of the weird thing
of, you know, growing up as a
girl in 1970s, 1980s Britain,
you know, kind of dominated by Benny Hill
and raunchy postcards at the seaside
and just all the things
that kind of come with that.
Nobody even thinks about it,
just think it's very funny.
But if you're a young girl,
it's actually not very funny,
but you just learn to
have to laugh about it.
This is so pre MeToo
that it seems like another world
and yet we still get all of
that misogyny and sexism.
There was a dress code
inside of the White House.
Was kind of very much Fox News,
if anyone's seen the film Bombshell.
I mean, I thought that was actually,
would've been good
preparation for watching
before I kind of went in there.
And I was always aware that I had to
change the way I dress
somewhat, just so I blend in
so that nobody would
pay too much attention
and one of the funniest episodes came
when he thought I was a secretary
and I was told by a senior colleague,
you know, look, just
don't worry about that,
he'll forget who you are,
you didn't imprint, but if
you wear the same dress,
he'll remember you.
Just make sure that every time you go in,
wear a different dress.
So, I had to actually get
quite a wardrobe of different dresses.
It's a theme we seem to be returning to.
Yeah.
It's basically like
some kind of camouflage.
It's like I'll wear my
jungle camouflage today
or my forest camouflage
or my snow camouflage.
It's just so that I
could just get in there,
try to do my job and get out again.
And I'm presuming this was different
to working under Obama?
Yeah.
I mean, nobody ever kind of went...
But that was the sort of theme then
when I get to the impeachment as well,
nobody there gave me a dress code.
Actually, I looked back in
some of the pictures there,
I thought, what the heck was I wearing?
But anyway.
I find it actually quite funny
because it was almost like
being in some endless school play
where you've got the various costumes,
and I guess I was just
trying to be a tree.
Kind of when I got into the Oval Office,
just so that nothing
untoward would happen.
I'm now imagining you in--
Yeah, I know, exactly, the tree thing.
You know, the kid in the tree,
hey mum, hey dad, I'm a tree.
Well, I shouldn't say in
the corner, in the oval.
Yeah, exactly.
Potted plant, potted plant.
I've not been in there myself, but--
There are no trees in the oval.
They're usually outside
in the rose garden.
But the whole point of
all that was, you know,
get in there without any incident,
but really focus on engaging
with the other counterparts.
I never got treated like that
by the national security team
or the national security advisor.
It was just this weird coterie around...
And it was weird.
It was like being in Alice
In Wonderland as well,
and there were so many analogies.
I do feel that, you know,
strange things in my childhood,
like reading Alice in Wonderland,
Alice Through the Looking Glass
and other things prepared me better
than all of the years of
fancy educations and degrees.
Although it was very important
to obviously know Russia
and know your stuff,
but for those moments, that
wasn't the best preparation.
And it isn't a partisan point
from your point of view,
this was the administration,
you would've worked
for any administration,
your point is you wanted
to bring your expertise,
but this was how you found
this particular administration.
Yeah.
And you mentioned that education,
it's a key part of what you've
written about your journey
from the coal house, as you
put it to the White House.
And worryingly, in your
journey, which you...
There are lots of bits of luck as well.
The particular time you were born,
the education that was then available.
You really talk about the fact
that you don't think it's getting better.
In fact it's getting worse,
that social mobility, not just in the UK,
you've looked at it through
the prism of the US as well, is worse.
It is.
It's got much worse over
time, exactly right.
The kind of opportunities that I had,
including in the UK for
basically having my education,
going to university paid for,
I mean those have all shrunk.
There's just a lot less funding up there.
I mean, there's been expansion of places,
but a lot less funding for people.
And just that threat of enormous debt
is really too much for people.
Thinking and contemplating that,
in the United States,
what you think of as
the land of opportunity,
anyone can make it,
there's only a five percent chance now.
Very different from what
it was in the late 1980s
to do what I've done
in terms of going from
the bottom one percent
to the top one percent kind of thing.
And everybody should have an opportunity
to be able to move forward in life.
It doesn't have to be in elite education,
but to get the kind of job that they want,
to get the qualifications
that they need as well,
we need to really think about that.
I mean, there's been a
lot of movement forward
on socioeconomic background,
on race and on gender, class
to some degree here in the UK
and in the United States,
class gets subsumed by
race in many contexts.
But in terms of regional differentiation,
that's not the case.
I mean I still see a huge divide
in the United Kingdom
between north and south,
I've just been up north to see my mother
and family and friends,
and it just seems like
London is a total world apart
and it's the same for people
in different boroughs in London.
The city couldn't be more
different from Tower Hamlets
and things like this, for example.
And in the United States,
it's very similar as well.
People from, what we
now call the rust belt,
we used to be the old
industrial heartland of the United States,
feel that they might as
well live on another planet,
as have these affiliations and affinities
with Washington DC.
That's why January sixth happened.
That's why people stormed the Capitol.
The Capitol, the White
House is the people's house,
you know supposed to
be the people's house,
but the Capitol is
supposed to be their symbol
of representative democracy,
and yet people saw it as a citadel,
a kind of a forbidden fortress
that wasn't representing them anymore,
and just this kind of,
this upsurge and this insurgency.
I watched that, I thought,
oh my God, look where we've got to here.
That's the kind of epitome
of these kinds of problems
when people feel that
they're excluded in some way,
and that sense of
representation is broken down.
And you talk in some detail
about some of the things
you think need to change
at the heart of education,
but also what others can do
when they do have positions
of power and influence.
I've got to ask, what does
your mum make of your journey?
Well, I think she's a bit bemused by it,
but she's pretty pleased at the same time.
But it's funny.
Like she took it all in her stride
and I talk in the book about
when I was out looking for that suit
that I wore at the impeachment.
My mum's just, you know,
sees a sales rack and sees this suit,
and she says, Fiona come over here,
look, there's a suit for sale.
Do you need it for that
impeachment thingy?
She didn't even kind of fully
connect about what it was
and she just thought it was a great thing
that I went there and told
the truth and did my job.
She wasn't passing the big
historical implications of that.
My mum's a very practical
person, former midwife.
If a baby needed delivering in
some difficult circumstances,
off she would go and just do it
without thinking about
all the larger context.
She'd just get on with it.
Well, you seem to have
adopted a similar style.
Thank you very much for talking to me
and to all of us today.
Oh, thanks so much for
having me, Emma, thank you.
And thank you to you for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.